possible puisque vous avez un petit
conseil vous voilà pour est un petit
conseil pas ça c'est un petit peu
croustillant à moi ex conseil d'euronext
hottinguer restons bien sûr ah non moi
je moi j'ai pas de conseil à donner les
gens avec amusez vous éclatez vous
passez chez vous merci j'ai pris je
voulais vous dire aimer ce que vous avez
vous un conseil à un petit secret
rentrée bien sûr on sait sexo oui c'est
que selon moi je pense qu'il faut se
laisser aller
ah oui il faut pas voilà il faut pas
essayer de faire le mieux le plus fort
le plus tôt comble pas le plus mal il
faut se laisser aller
mais ça mais c'est vrai ça tu as les
yeux plus gros que le bon est ce que
conseille week-end un petit conseil sait
flatter votre femme
elle en a besoin a besoin de tous les
jours c'est jamais assez d'accord
abattre et gilles verdez sait caresser
les cheveux
oui comme sa partie arrière car et ça
c'est quand même plutôt cette étude
c'est bizarre il désire c'est un mec à
ben oui voilà on y voyant un logement il
va en arriver là que novice d'appeler la
police à kohat
merci alors castaldi est ce que vous
avez un conseil
oui j'ai un vrai conseil pour les hommes
il faut penser à sa femme en premier
avant de passer son plaisir à soi
victor plaisir bien absolument avec
géraldine je pense qu'il faut valoriser
ses défauts c'est à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui sont complexés il
faut il faut se lâcher il faut lâcher
prise en fait d'accord quelles que
soient vos complet celle abri dorment
lâcher prise way lâcher la prairie sein
d'un conseil mais si je vous ai envie de
vite rentrer chez soi après
allez y mais nous avons un conseil oui
passer chez moi le vrai conseil c'est
plus cydia qui nous donnerait conseil
une info qui peut changer votre vie
les femmes ne peuvent pas avoir
d'orgasmes si elles ont les pieds froids
c'est pour ça que c'est pas glamour tu
crois qu on fait l'amour dans un
paisible et t3 c'est pour ça que c'est
pas glamour mais recommandé de mettre
des chaussettes
ouais c'est glamour bah écoutez votre
premier conseil sexo quelque chose de
chaussettes des délits et de cyril vous
en avez un forcément un de conseil louis
sûr bien sûr ne fait rien et attendait
que ça se passe
et
[Applaudissements]